ad astra sends Brad Pitt to the far
reaches of space on a quest for his
father the truth and a sense of deeper
meaning if you're wondering what it all
adds up to let's break down the ending a
major takeaways of ad astra after space
conn determines that Clifford McBride is
likely behind the destructive antimatter
pulse it kicks off the movies plots his
son Roy is suspicious on a mission to
Mars in an effort to establish
communication with the elder McBride
voyons of journeying all the way to
Neptune when he discovers that space
Conn was right his father is still alive
and was at least partly responsible for
the antimatter surge a surge came after
the crew of his station staged a deadly
mutiny irrevocably damaging the battery
powering the station but the true
tragedy at least in Clifford sighs as a
result of all their research which shows
no sign of intelligent alien life in the
universe
although the lima project compiled reams
of data about outlying planets and
systems it didn't find what Clifford was
really looking for Clifford was so
determined to find new life that he was
willing to abandon his family and even
kill for it although the information he
did gather is valuable for him it's not
enough way McBride is uniquely qualified
for the mission to determine the fate of
Project Lima there's his family
connection to the project's long-lost
leader and the fact that he is like Neil
Armstrong was described to be an almost
supernaturally reserved man even working
in dangerous conditions in deep space
his pulse goes no higher than 80 bpm and
he deals with a bad news about his
father with a steely calm now we're
counting on you to help us find him are
you with us
yes I am sir as this quality that comes
in extra handy when Roy realizes what
Space Commerce really up to specifically
the agency is out so that will cross him
and kill Clifford the secret plan all
along is to observe Roy's attempt to
establish communication with Clifford
using Clifford's response to figure out
where he is and then travel there to
finish him off with a nuclear weapon
once he figures it out boy proves more
than a match for the other team
successfully sabotaging their mission
before journeying to Neptune in peace
the central message of ad astra is best
summed up by voice words to his father
just before they leave project lima roy
tells his father that what cliff has
proven that there's no alien life to be
found it's just as important as finding
another world full of intelligence by
learning there is no intelligent life in
the known universe
terrific Shona such as Roy puts it we're
all we've got
speaking to Digital Spy white a director
James gray explained that the idea of
looking for answers in alien life isn't
a particularly appealing idea to him
gray said the idea that there's his
little green men out there that will
ever save us or eat us to me that's more
horrifying than having to rely on other
people with the lima projects antimatter
battery damaged the station is a lost
cause actively endangering life on other
planets as it breaks down clifford comer
parrots but thankfully Roy has arrived
with a solution of source the nuclear
bomb space comm intended to use on
Clifford after getting his father out to
the station Roy uses a bomb for part of
his intended purpose blowing up a
station and getting rid of the battery
it's an ignominious end for lima
projects which sets out on a hopeful
mission before spiraling into madness
violence and catastrophic loss of life
Clifford run away from earth hoping to
find answers but ended up creating more
problems underlining one of the movie's
major themes running away from problems
or meant to face head-on can only lead
to disappointment
somewhere between Earth and Neptune it
seems pretty obvious that cliff McBride
has lost his freakin mind
but one of the interesting things about
had asked her is up with Roy's voyage we
get to follow in Cliff's footsteps and
see exactly how his marbles spilled out
boys narration tells us there are
physical strains affecting his mental
health
like the extended time spent in
zero-gravity there's also the crushing
isolation of space something white
commits to facing as he continues on his
quest to find his father going past the
moon past Mars and then all the way to
Neptune are you ready
grinning voice journey mirrors what must
have been his father's in a lot of ways
including the death toll when boy
reaches his father we learned the
antimatter surges on something cliff has
been causing on purpose it struggles
against his crew he says cause the
damage that led to the antimatter
instability this is something boy's
familiar with because his trek through
the Stars was left its own trail of
collateral damage with few exceptions
just about everyone who's been at Roy's
side throughout his journey is dead by
the end of the movie though he doesn't
mean for it to happen
he indirectly causes the death of the
surviving crew on the ship to Neptune
just as clip and directly unleashes the
antimatter surge that threatens our
solar system after they escape project
Lima Clift attaches himself from Roy
guaranteeing his own certain death he
has more than a few reasons for doing it
first there are the consequences you
might have to face upon returning to
earth he doesn't know that his crimes
have been swept under the rug and so us
no reason to think will be shown any
mercy second what he may refuse to admit
it to himself what he calls his destiny
as proven to be a sham considering
everything he's done for that destiny
how could he not want to end things
finally as he tells Roy his lonely void
has become his home he has no desire to
return to Earth ad astra has been
compared to a number of classic movies
from the ore and wonder of 2001 a Space
Odyssey the character study a first man
and the grounded thrills of gravity has
also drawn comparisons to Apocalypse Now
in the wave voyage drawn deeper and
deeper into space and his dangerous
quest but ad astra is fundamentally
about the desire for connection between
parents and their offspring and between
people in general and the dark places
people can be driven to when that
connection is lost it's a very human
story dealing with our connection to
humanity in many ways Roy McBride's
journey is a terribly sad one he's
betrayed by his employers and faced the
reality of his father's crimes potential
insanity and then death he loses the
parent he journeyed billions of miles to
save but in spite of that loss the
movies message remains hopeful as Roy
tells Clifford we're all we've got
and those bonds are strong enough to
take us all to Neptune and back check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos by your
favorite sci-fi movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss
single one
[Applause]
[Music]